Time and Time and Again the clearest
indicators of when a fiat currency is
going to decline into
you know collapse is
when those who are holding its debt sell
the debt and the government Central Bank
has to print money to buy that debt in
large size while that's going down
those are the most important indicators
so that you can see it again I want to
repeat selling the debt
so that there's a big Supply demand
imbalance
and the Central Bank having to come in
there and buy the debt that no one else
will buy in large quantity so that what
then there's a currency devaluation you
have those three things aligned the
currency devaluation going down at the
same time as those other two things are
happening and that's been a classic it's
like a bank run you know they come to
the bank there's not enough money in the
bank and so they have to make up the
difference by the printing of money